tomás de Torquemada was the controlling
force of the Spanish Inquisition he
presided over the systematic purging of
the so called heretic Jews that has gone
down in history as one of the worst
religious persecutions of all time but
was he the monster that history is
painted well in this week's biographic
s-- we uncover the real story of tomás
de Torquemada tomás de Torquemada was
born in 1420 in or around the village of
ADA led in the kingdom of Old Castile in
modern-day Spain the torquemada's were
of Jewish heritage however Tomas is
forebears had converted to Catholicism
to become what were known as conversos
or converted ones his was a
distinguished family with an uncle John
who had joined the Dominican Order and
was making advancement in the Royal
Palace in Rome
in 1431 John de Torquemada was made
master of the palace and then in 1439 a
cardinal with an uncle in such a honey
position in the Catholic Church the path
was set for young to master make his own
mark within the church from a young age
he seized the opportunity he was a
diligent students who develops a
reputation as a pious and humble young
man prior to the age of 10 he was
admitted to the San Pablo Dominican
monastery for the next two decades his
life revolved around ecclesiastical
study prayer confession and church
custom at around the age of 35 he became
pryor of the Dominican convent at
Segovia for the next 20 years talk--i
Mata presided over his small parish
living the life of a humble quiet man of
God he developed a reputation as an
energetic and fearless preacher of the
word and a strict disciplinarian the
fact that he was strictest on himself
caused the people in his community to
look at his as a fine example of piety
and holiness he refused to eat meat he
slept on a bare board and would not wear
anything other than his old habit he was
also a voracious reader and had a
fascination with architecture especially
that of the church
[Music]
up until the 15th century the rulers of
Castile and Aragon governed a series of
separate district kingdoms within the
Iberian Peninsula it was the marriage of
Isabella of Castile to Ferdinand of
Aragon in 1469 which began the gradual
process of the unification that would
lead to the creation of modern day Spain
it was around 14-7 the UN Torquemada
became acquainted with princess Isabella
who was then in her young 20s
the princess was spending quite a lot of
time in Segovia and with Torquemada
having established quite a reputation as
a holy man of note he was retained as
her confessor
at first he declined to accept the offer
but was won over by the princess's
insistence on December the 13th 1474
Isabella was crowned queen of Castile
and Leon her relationship with
Torquemada had grown and she came to
rely on him for advice Isabella and
Torquemada they were both obsessed with
rooting out religious heresy and the
purity of the church both the Queen and
her husband King Ferdinand had a high
opinion of the humble priest and he was
quickly promoted within the order if he
had been ambitious he may have ascended
to a cosmonaut ship like his uncle or
even to the office of Pope but talk
Amada he had no such lofty intentions he
was content to live the life of a simple
monk in May of 1475 the Portuguese
invaded Spain in an attempt to seize the
crown away from Isabella and Ferdinand
the bloody war was waged for nearly a
year culminating in the Spanish victory
at the Battle of Toro on March the 1st
1476 in the wake of this great victory
Isabella rode around the countryside
holding court in every town that she
came across there she would hear
complaints about murderers thieves and
other wrongdoers using her authority as
monarch to fast-track judicial process
she would order the guilty to either be
shot or beheaded immediately this she
did with a cold and clinical precision
at this time Tokomaru was busy with
organizing the construction of a new
dominican monastery at Avila
[Music]
Jews had been living in Spain for some
1,500 years with about 80,000 of them at
the time Isabella was queen this was
compared to some six million Christians
unlike France and England's the Spanish
had not expelled the Jews but they had
forced many of them to convert to
Christianity these were the ones who
were known as conversos many within the
realm however did not put any stock in
the Christian sincerity of the conversos
they were believed to be false converts
who practice their own Jewish religion
while professing Christianity this was
seen by many in positions of power as a
direct threat to the security of the
realm in general and the church in
particular in the eyes of the Queen this
faith amounted to Paris II and it was
something that she simply would not
tolerate in fact she would not put up
with any form of religious hypocrisy it
was during a visit to Seville in 1477
that she first became interested in
adopting an Inquisition or investigation
into the religious state of the kingdom
the following year a papal bull was
issued by Pope Sixtus the 4th granting
permission to establish an inquisition
within castile the petitions of the Pope
requesting the Inquisition had been
written by Torquemada and Cardenal
Mendoza but Isabella she moved
cautiously she was of the opinion that
poor training was the main reason that
Jewish converts were not fully adhering
to the faith and so she put the emphasis
on religious education the queen
appointed two of her most trusted church
advisors Cardenal Mendoza and the future
Archbishop of Granada Hernando de tavera
to the task of reeducate in the way
would conversing a program was put in
place in Seville by which local priests
would retrain the misguided conversos
but after two years with very little
headway being made Isabella had to
concede that stronger measures were
needed she remains reluctant to enact
the Inquisition but pressure came upon
her from her advisers including
Torquemada to do so even a husband King
Ferdinand was in favor ever the
pragmatist he foresaw the confiscation
of conversa property as a much-needed
revenue gathering source for the state
[Music]
finally and against her better judgment
Isabella issued a royal decree on
September the 27th 1480 establishing the
tribunal of the Holy Office of the
Inquisition
the papal bull authorizing the
Inquisition had given Isabella and
Ferdinand the freedom to select the
members who made up the Inquisition
tribunal they chose tomás de Torquemada
along with Cardenal Mendoza and two
other Dominicans fray Miguel Murillo and
fray Juan de San martín Mendoza took the
position of chief judge while talk Amada
took the position of consulting expert
the other two members were the active
inquisitors who sought out and brought
heretics before the tribunal the first
area of focus for the Inquisition was
the almost entirely Jewish city of
Seville the arrival of inquisitors
dressed in distinctive white robes and
black hoods caused panic among the
conversa community with around 4,000
people fleeing Seville still the
inquisitors set about their work with
ruthless efficiency the first public
execution took place on February the 6th
1481 on that day six people were burnt
to death setting the stage for the
horror there was to unfold over the
coming months and years from Seville the
Inquisition spread throughout the
kingdom with tribunals set up in Cordoba
yen and the religious capital of Toledo
a pattern was soon established that
would begin with the people of the town
being prepared by having the fear of God
preached to them from the pulpit then
the inquisitors would arrive in the town
and the Edict of grace would be read
this was a call to come forth and
confess your lack of faith those who did
so and renounce their Judaism could hope
for mercy those who didn't would face
the full wrath of the inquisitors those
who were taken into detention would have
all of their property taken away from
them this would obviously leave their
family in a hopeless situation the
primary goal of the interrogators was to
obtain a confession it didn't matter if
it came voluntary or if torture had to
be used to extract it methods of torture
progressed from foot roasting in which
the suspects feet were lava din fat and
then held over a burning fire to the
Judas cradle a device composed of a tall
thin stool with a triangular shaped seat
in which the victim was slowly impale
and then there was the rack in which
case the victim was tied to a wooden
frame and their body was stretched as
the bars moved in opposite directions
such torture would convince even the
most innocent of people to confess still
such a coerced confession was not
legally binding
it had to be afterwards confirmed by the
suspect for it to hold any weight the
trial that was held would be the
defendants only opportunity to defend
himself if he was able to we would call
upon witnesses to prove his innocence or
to cast doubt upon the veracity of the
accuser if found guilty the person could
be reconciled or penance stiff they
demonstrated contrite miss they would
lose all their property and have to
undergo such punishments as whipping or
a term of imprisonment those who refused
to denounce Judaism would be condemned
to the flames
the Inquisition created an atmosphere of
fear throughout the kingdom one of its
most chilling aspects was that it
thrived on a diet of anonymous
accusation then when a suspect was
forced to confess he was required to
produce names of others who had been
co-conspirators with him by 1483 the
Inquisition had become a monster that
was completely out of control
Isabella's initial goal was simply to
weed out the false converts among the
conversa Jews but the climate of
accusation and torture had led to
something far far more sinister with no
centralized control the various
tribunals around the kingdom were
operating according to their own
dictates news was constantly being
received by the Pope in Rome of excesses
that went beyond the powers that he had
given in his papal bull this caused
tension between the Pope and Queen
Isabella in order to settle the
situation Isabella turned to her advice
at tomás de Torquemada it was decided
that all the powers of the Inquisition
would be decentralized with Torquemada
himself at the head he had the skills
and experience it was believed to please
both the monarch and the Pope at the
same time the Pope agreed and in October
of 1483 he named Torquemada the
Inquisitor general of Castile and Leon
[Music]
in contrast deep histories painting him
as an eager persecutor of Jews who was
chomping at the bit to torture them the
truth is that Torquemada
would rather not have taken up the
position he would have preferred to
continue to live the simple life of a
monk yes having accepted the position he
did take it on with full force not with
the goal of persecuting the Jews there
but ensuring that all Catholics were
true and loyal Catholics he saw the
Inquisition not as an instrument of
cruel terror but as a vehicle for
necessary reform toka murder began his
oversight of the Inquisition by doing
away with the worst excesses of his
predecessors putting in place a system
of judicial process he then improved the
conditions for people who were
imprisoned under the Inquisition talk
Amada next set about refining the stages
of the Inquisition process the Edict of
grace would be read up to three times in
a period of 40 days given for repentant
ones to come forward a person could only
be convicted on the testimony of two
witnesses and now the complaints had to
be in writing and they had to be signed
once the person was denounced by two
witnesses he would be investigated
usually without his knowledge if
evidence of false religious worship was
clear certain and specific the person
would be put before the court talk Amada
required that a person's trial must be
held within three days of his arrest the
charges against him would be stated and
he would be urged to confess to his
guilt if he refused up to two more
hearings would be held only after the
third hearing with the interrogation
begin Tok Amado produced a hands book to
help his inquisitors to identify
heretical conversos giveaway signs of
their heresy were such things as cooking
all their meals for the week ends on a
Friday night if they got their supplies
from Jewish rather than Christian
suppliers and if they were known not to
eat pork despite the fact that his name
has been forever linked with the worst
excesses of the Inquisition's torture
processes the reality is that Torquemada
was responsible for mitigating the worst
excesses of the process he stipulated
that it was not to be used as a means of
punishment but strictly for obtaining
information related to the charge of
hands furthermore torture could only be
administered with the written approval
of the bishop of the diocese and the
visa of the Supreme Court in a dish
a doctor had to be present throughout
the torture process Torquemada did away
with some of the more barbarous methods
of torture and replaced them with what
was known as the water cure the
interrogated person would be strips
naked and tied with cords upon a wooden
ladder the nostrils were stopped and his
jaws were held apart by tongues then a
piece of linen was placed over his mouth
water was then slowly poured onto the
cloth to travel down the throat the
sensation that resulted was that one was
suffocating however it rarely resulted
in long-term harm and usually resulted
in a confession being obtained
Torquemada organized a sonata then
quizzes at Seville during which he
impressed upon the tribunal members his
new rules
he then convened tribunals in all Jewish
strongholds including Seville Cordoba
Gian and Ciudad rial with the
Inquisition now ironed out in Castile
talk Amada now set about implementing it
in Aragon this was a challenging
assignment the Jews held plenty of
positions of power and these men were
naturally resistant to the Inquisition
moving in the governor of Aragon along
with most of the judges and lawyers in
the state were all converses they all
banded together in opposition to the
work of Torquemada still the chief
Inquisitor forged ahead he appointed two
of his best men as inquisitors for
Aragon leaving his men tear it he then
returned to focus on carrying out the
Inquisition in Castile meanwhile Jewish
leaders in both states were organizing
an opposition to the Inquisition
a great campaign for democracy was
launched two monks were sent to Cordoba
to beseech the Queen's but an end to the
Inquisition the men offered large sums
of money to the crown
however Isabella rejected all of their
efforts now desperate the Jewish leaders
began to speak of assassinating the
inquisitors a group of prominent Jews
met together and agreed to hire a gang
of cutthroats to carry out the
assassinations they began by disposing
of high-ranking priests within the
Inquisition father Peter abuse was
kneeling in prayer before the Blessed
Sacrament when a gangster crept in and
stabbed him in the back the king and
queen were outraged that this attack and
went all out to hunt down the people who
were responsible the gang who had been
employed to carry out the killings they
were rounded up
it's executed meanwhile the death of the
priests who had immediately been raised
to sainthood led to a backlash against
the conversing any opposition to the
Inquisition in Aragon now came to an end
allowing Torquemada free reign to bring
the jews there to his true faith in the
course of his enquiries into the Jewish
activities Torquemada uncovered a plot
by converse own leaders in toledo to
seize control of the city during the
1485 corpus christi prosecution and
murder all the leading Christians as a
result a large number of Jewish leaders
they were put to death after 12 years
the Inquisition had still not managed to
stomp out the Jewish heresy problem
Torquemada was of the belief that the
reason that the conveyers were not fully
engaged with Catholicism was because
they still associated with the Jewish
community only by putting an end to this
association with the problem be solved
consequently he began putting pressure
on the king and queen to issue an edict
expelling all Jews from Spain then in
1495 Jews and six confessors were
accused of crucifying and murdering a
Christian child in the village of the
Gardea the accusation it was probably
false but it led to an unprecedented
anti-semitic backlash finally in March
of 1492 Isabella and Ferdinand signed
their names to a document which ordered
that all Jews who had not converted to
Christianity were to leave the kingdom
by August the 2nd 1492 around 160,000
people managed to get out before the
deadline most of them sold their
possessions for a pittance and were
forced to travel as far as Africa the
Balkans and Rome before finally finding
a place to settle many of them unable to
find a place where they would be
accepted straggled back to Spain to be
baptized as Catholics others reportedly
paid exorbitant prices for passage on
ships only to be killed at sea and
thrown overboard the number of Jews who
remained in Spain as conversos was far
greater than those who had left and
despite the worst efforts of the
Inquisition they remained Jewish
believers at heart
however these converse now had no Jewish
cultural support to back them up they
were completely on their own
synagogues throughout the lands were
taken over and claimed for the Catholic
Church by now Tok Amado was at the
height
power he had unfettered control over the
Inquisition and was a key player in the
royal household the combination of the
Inquisition and the Jewish expulsion had
ensured that Catholicism would remain
untainted
[Music]
in 1494 Torquemada now aged 74 began to
suffer the effects of old age
his body lacks the energy he once had
and he struggled to complete his duties
as Grand Inquisitor Pope Gregory the
fourth appointed for assistant
inquisitors to lighten the load in that
same year Isabella and Ferdinand gifted
him the jewish cemetry at a villa for
him to use as his own monastery it was
here that he died peacefully on
September the 16th 1498
the Inquisition was to survive
Torquemada by 300 years spreading
throughout the Spanish held territory
including Naples the Spanish Netherlands
and the territory held by Spain and the
Americas the Inquisition remains one of
the worst examples of man's inhumanity
towards man and the man who led it tomás
de Torquemada is one of history's most
hated figures so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below don't
forget to subscribe it got brand new
videos twice a week also hit that
notification bell if you actually want
to hear about those videos subscribe
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]